T
IT'S LIKE TO BE THERE WITH THEIR
HEARING WHAT THEY'RE FEELING.
>> EVERYONE THEY ARE CALLING US.
IT'S HOPEFUL.
>> WE ARE GOING TO POLAND AND
THE WILL PROBABLY GO ELSEWHERE.
TO STAY ON THE BOMBING COMES
DOWN A LITTLE BIT.
>> WERE FAMILY HAPPY TO BE
TOGETHER NOW.
WE WILL HAVE A VICTORY I
BELIEVE.
>> Jeanine: WHAT WE'VE JUST
SEEN IN THOSE INTERVIEWS ARE THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE BEING SACRIFICED
BECAUSE OF FOLKS ON THE
INTERNATIONAL STAGE ARE TAKEN
OVER A COUNTRY WITH LITTLE IF
ANY PUSHBACK FROM THE REST THE
WORLD.
ONE OF THE THINGS I WANT TO ADD
TO WHAT JESSE WAS SAYING I HAVE
HEARD THAT THE RUSSIANS ARE AT A
DISTINCT ADVANTAGE IN TERMS OF
THEIR ABILITY TO WAGE WAR AT
NIGHT.
MORE SO THAN THE UKRAINIANS BUT
THE RUSSIANS AND IS MUCH AS YOU
WANT THEM STAND THERE AND FIGHT,
THESE PEOPLE DON'T HAVE THE
CAPABILITIES OF THE HUNDRED AND
90 MILITARIES TO FIGHT BACK.
THIS IS SOME KIND OF THEORETICAL
SCENARIOS THESE ARE REAL LIFE
PEOPLE WHO ARE GOING TO DIE.
AND IN THE END WHAT FRUSTRATES
ME --
WHAT WE DID IS WE CREATED A
DEPENDENCE ON RUSSIAN OIL,
EUROPE AND GERMANY, GERMANY
BECAUSE THEY ARE DEPENDENT ON
RUSSIAN OIL AND GAS.
WE CLOSE ON OUR PIPELINES SO WE
ARE DEPENDENT SO WHAT HAPPENS?
YOU'RE RIGHT GERALDO ABOUT CHINA
AND RUSSIA BECAUSE THEY CAN SELL
OIL TO CHINA.
SOME OF THE QUESTION IS WHAT
SANCTIONS DO WE HAVE THAT WILL
MAKE A DIFFERENCE?
I DON'T KNOW?
BUT WHAT I DO KNOW IS YOU CANNOT
TRIED TO CONVINCE OR A THUG LIKE
THIS TO STOP.
HE IS ON HIS WAY, HE'S O